Michigan Congressman John Conyers is
stepping down as the top Democrat on the
House Judiciary Committee he faces
allegations that he settled a claim of
sexual harassment by one female former
staffer and harassed others in a
statement yesterday Conyers said I
denied these allegations I look very
much forward to vindicating myself and
my family before his announcement House
Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi called
Conyers an icon with a record of
defending women she was asked about the
unidentified accusers did you believe
John Conyers I don't know who they are
do you they have not really come forward
and and that gets you don't know if you
believe the accusations what that's for
the ethics committee to review but I
believe he understands what is at stake
here and he will do the right thing
after Conyers gave up his committee post
Pelosi said in a statement no matter how
great an individual's legacy it is not a
license for harassment CBS News
contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for the
Washington Post
good morning morning so you have the
leader of the Democratic Party
essentially questioning the identity of
the accusers right hailing John Conyers
is an icon and someone who has done a
lot to protect women over time how much
has she complicated her own party's
position oh I think she's complicating
it for sure look nobody's perfect on
either side of this debate Republicans
and Democrats both have guilty actors or
certainly misbehaving actors I think the
problem for her yesterday was she knew
that his decision to step down from his
perch was coming yes exactly and and I
think he was struggling to get Conyers
to get to that point ideally she
probably would have showed up yesterday
with him having already done this and
would have taken a different tact the
Congressional Black Caucus is a very
powerful block of the House Democratic
caucus
he's the founder of the Congressional
Black Caucus I think a lot of this for
her had to do with some internal
political dynamics that they were
concerned that their founder that their
most senior member was going to be
that's the criticism is that politics
Lee took the head it was in front of the
idea about what's doing what's right
exactly and she kept talking about due
process look as we understand he'd gone
through that due process that secretive
due process you know that allowed for
this settlement to happen in the first
place and we don't know how that process
and I think
that's why people get frustrated yes I
think if that had been a Republican I
think many people believe she would have
Lizzy what I had a different he would
have had a totally different take on it
absolutely so is there a double standard
do you think for politicians well
there's certainly a different standard
the fact that they can settle these
things so secretively and that money can
be paid out either for this or for other
workplace issues I think you know more
than anything Congress is beginning to
realize the men at least certainly are
beginning to realize they don't serve in
a frat house they serve in the House of
Representatives and in the Senate and
and the time has come and the change is
coming I think one of the things we've
learned here at CBS and you reported in
Washington Post too is that many
staffers don't even know how to report
up so a sexual harassment claim they
don't even know what to do what is
Congress doing this week to change that
so the house is going to pass a
resolution that essentially mandates
sexual harassment training for members
and all staff the bigger step will be if
they go into this labyrinth of steps you
have to take that can take up to a year
to settle these claims and if members
decide to publicly release the
information about these settlements I
think that would be a bigger change
people forget the legislative branch is
not go hold into the same transparency
and privacy laws that the that the
executive branch is that would be a big
change that would probably help settle
this and let's switch gears and talk
about the deputy director of the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau she
filed a lawsuit to block president
Trump's appointment of Mick Mulvaney
yeah what are you hearing from Capitol
Hill well welllook Democrats defend this
agency it was Elizabeth Warren's idea
before she was even in the Senate they
will stand with this new deputy director
in her lawsuit but Republicans and the
president certainly don't like it Tom
cotton the Republican senator from
Arkansas last night called in an
unconstitutional agency it'll be an
interesting legal battle for sure what
about this to-do list the Congress long
and not a lot of days you have 12
legislative days until Christmas they
got a lot to do all right
always good to have you see you